hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out the new portal by facebook
and i'm so excited about this because i
absolutely
love connected technology anything that
can keep me connected to my friends to
my family
and mostly to my sister because that's
probably the person that i talk to the
absolute most
speaking of my sister we're kind of
doing this video together but she's
doing a video as well on her channel i'm
unboxing the portal plus this is a 15.6
inch screen and she's unboxing the other
version of portal which is a 10.1 inch
screen
so join us both for this fun unboxing
and testing this out a huge thank you to
facebook for sponsoring this video i am
so excited to try this out
so i'm going to unbox this my sister is
going to unbox hers
and then we're going to try these out
together
so i guess i don't really need a knife
do i well what fun is that
oh oh wow look at this
here it is wow this is actually way
bigger than i thought but what i like
about that
is the screen size no matter where i am
in the room i'm gonna actually be able
to see this and it also
has a framing option so it will keep you
in the frame as i move about my room
hi this is hi they've actually labeled
the plastic stickies
one two three
oh whoa that's so great
so this camera is a 12 megapixel camera
and it also has 140 degree field of view
so that's
pretty wide angle which is great
especially if you have it placed in a
room and you want to be able to capture
everything
so let's try this out i keep talking
about features and not showing you
[Music]
whoa it's already starting up this is
incredible oh
yes okay it's checking for updates log
in with facebook
all right see how smart camera keeps you
in frame whoa
hello no way look at you keeping me in
the frame
you guys can't even tell like you
obviously can tell because i'm
what this is nuts hello i'm over here
you guys can see that this is crazy
wow i'm so far away well what if i go
over here really okay it kept me in
frame pretty quickly
that's pretty awesome it also works with
amazon alexa which is super exciting
call my sister hello hello
i love the fact that jenna's actually
downstairs right now while i'm unboxing
this
hello hello it's really funny because
i'm editing a video about four oh my
gosh she was not joking this is
incredible
this is actually this i swear to you
this was not planned at all
cool because i've already been playing
with it for two weeks
this is my first time i'm unboxing right
now what happens if i turn it
dude this is super cool i'm so excited
well i'm going to carry on with my
unboxing and then i'll see you in a
little bit
to finish the rest of this video is that
the 15.6
inch display it is and you're doing the
10.1 inch
portal this is the portal plus well we
have both of them but yeah i did unbox
it
another thing that's really cool is it
features smart sound so it does a really
great job of balancing out voices and
removing background sounds
because privacy is such a huge concern
with a lot of people and as it should be
because that's something that's
extremely important
facebook also includes one of these
little camera covers just like so
and there's a little button at the top
that will automatically turn the camera
off and
on so as you can see here this little
red light means that the microphone and
the video is off the camera doesn't use
facial recognition so everything that's
happening is all happening locally here
on the portal
you can also go into your facebook
activity and delete any voice commands
at any time i also love
that in here in the settings you can add
a passcode and you can make that
passcode up to 4 to 12 digits so
especially if you have this in your
house and you don't want other people to
have access to it
that is an easy solution well now that
i've unboxed it i'm going to take this
downstairs set it up in my kitchen where
it will now be living
and i'll give you guys a demo of how it
works the portal by facebook is all set
up you guys just saw the unboxing and
now i'm going to give jenna a call and
we're going to test this out hey portal
call jenna izarick calling jenna as a
wreck
[Music]
hi i was just watching some facebook
videos
what were you what were you already
watching well i was watching animals and
then i was about to watch a science one
and then you called me so
here i am so okay so there's tyler back
there he's helping us film someone say
hi do you see him do you see him in your
screen
do you see him spotlight him i
spotlighted tyler
so now we're focused only on time
so you can because i can see what you
see up here look so
there you are i get on spotlight oh
spotlight me spotlight me
this is so cool it's crazy how the
framing
just keeps me in the frame look at you
so this is really cool so jen's gonna
play a song on spotify and if you guys
both have spotify premium
i can listen to the same song that she's
listening to
it also works with pandora as well i
know we were talking about spotify but i
got a little sidetrack
what are you doing
watching the weather what are you doing
right now
look today is going to be a beautiful
sunny day not a cloud in the sky
story time is over now that um that was
actually pretty cool what if i turn you
you i just turned you you look better on
here than real life
play some spotify okay i'm gonna switch
you back this way okay i'll switch you
that way too
the trash can keeps opening because it
keeps thinking that i'm saying things
open pan
i don't know oh a member of this call is
trying to share spotify
except with me
this is funny
[Music]
turn the music down so what else can we
do
tell me what you see
spotlight this baby maddie how come i
can't see
oh maddie oh shoot what did i do with
the dog
hi dog he doesn't understand you he
doesn't
understand he looks like a meatloaf he
looks like a loaf of bread
what if we're over here i still yes
you're still in the frame
you want your french fry toy is mommy
gonna give you a treat
oh do you want a treat stop saying his
trigger word
i was just talking to mom and dad on the
other portal in the kitchen
it's cool because like you don't have to
have a portal either you can just
use messenger yeah i was talking to the
little messenger they were on the phone
i got to see bo
it was so cute oh that's cute well i'm
going to make some eggs because i'm
hungry
no you have to stay on the call while i
make my eggs
why did i go no you absolutely
cannot i'm getting closer to the door
oh shoot this isn't working very well
something no you can't leave
no i need help can you see me making my
eggs
well this isn't fair because you can't
make me any did you see that
it's not do you think i should juggle
these eggs
i gotta wait with you now before i hang
up on you i know
wait it's framing me oh yeah
okay so here's the thing once i start
doing this i can't stop
throw in the pants
okay so the plan we're gonna go to
dinner
what was that sound i shut the door
the one thing that i do like is how does
it sound over there because
i'm being pretty loud over here oh you
sound great
you sound great as well if you're making
1a
well yeah i mean oh sorry tyler did you
want an egg
he said he's good i
i didn't even ask my guests if he wanted
an egg yeah
i gotta get a plate i need a plate i
need a plate
can you still see me yeah the trash can
keeps opening because it keeps thinking
that i'm saying open can
that's a problem
this egg is ready for a flip
hmm did you see my flip you missed my
flip you weren't even paying attention
to me
do it again i can't
i'm gonna finish making breakfast you go
on your hike and i'll see you later hey
portal any call
i had so much fun chatting with jenna
and this is going to be a really nice
integration i feel like to my home
but there's one last thing that i want
to show you guys it has
a l e x a built in so
what's the weather like today right now
in santa monica
it's 65 degrees fahrenheit with clear
skies and sun
today's forecast has lots of clouds it
also has the volume
up buttons too here and down
i just want to call jenna back again hey
portal call jenna he's eric
calling jenna as a wreck she might
actually be on her hike but if she has
her phone with her she can answer it on
messenger
i was like i wonder if jenna i was like
i wonder if she's on the hike yet let me
show you what i've done
oh now you're in the kitchen are you on
the other portal
i am whoa well guys thank you so much
for watching and a huge thank you to
jenna they're sharing
thank you no thank you jenna also did an
unboxing on her channel so i'll put a
link in the description to check that
out and also there's a link if you guys
want to check out the portal by facebook
as well
thanks again for watching thanks to
jenna thanks to facebook i'll see you
guys in my next video
bye hey portal hang up oh
my friend went away
you